Have you ever had an ex boyfriend that was incredibly insecure?
Or an ex girlfriend?
Somebody who need constant validation from you or compliments from you?
Tell me I'm pretty, tell me I'm smart.
What were you doing last Friday?
Why didn't you answer my phone call?
And they exhibited extreme signs of abandonment issues.
And it was something constant
that carried over into every single relationship.
Or worse. You are that person.
No shame in it. We all have our attachment disorders.
This is called ambivalent attachment disorder,
and it is one of the disorders
that Doctor Erica Commissar discusses in her book.
Children can struggle with this attachment disorder as well,
way before their adult year.
And they are very clingy with their parents,
are scared for them to leave,
and when they do come back,
they're very difficult to calm down.
It is also known as ancient resistant attachment disorder.
If a mother leaves back to work too soon in her child's infancy,
or is often on with her child,
they're sometimes they're not sometimes,
and the caregiving is inconsistent.
Just like all the other disorders we've already discussed.
Ambivalent attachment disorder is that child's coping mechanism
to deal with how they felt.
They weren't given consistent care when they were infants.
As adults, they become super clingy.
They have deep seated insecurities that you can't even begin to touch.
Because the truth is, it started when they were babies.
They need constant attention and validation.
Maybe They wanna be Instagram famous.
Maybe they need you texting them all the time.
That is this attachment disorder.
And I guarantee you you have dated someone.
Or maybe you are someone with that attachment disorder.
Look out for my next video on the next one.